[Musique]
est-ce qu'il vous est déjà arrivé en
sortant d'une réunion importante ou d'un
premier rendez vous amoureux de vous
dire j'aurais dû dire ça oui apparemment
oui hein c'est léger mais j'ai
l'impression que oui j'ai l'impression
que c'est partager aussi là la
conclusion la plus évidente à ces
réactions partagées est simple quelque
chose en nous tous quelque chose de très
humain donc nous a empêché de dire ce
qu'on devait dire au moment où on devait
le dire mais alors quel est ce frein qui
nous bloque et comment dépasser ce
blocage pour commencer à répondre à ces
questions j'aimerais vous plonger dans
une expérience et je vous invite à
fermer les yeux pour visualiser la
situation suivante c'est marrant
j'entends toujours des froissements
quand les gens ce ferment leurs yeux la
situation banque est la suivante vous
êtes au mariage de votre meilleur ami
dont le frère du marié est chargé de
réaliser un beau discours à la fois
festif et émouvant et vous avez hâte de
l'entendre parce que vous savez que ce
discours sera exceptionnel tout autour
de vous les invités tout fringant eux
aussi impatient de commencer et c'est
alors que le marié votre meilleure amie
dont tu viens vous voir paniqué et vous
demande un énorme service
son frère un empêchement de dernière
minute et vous demandent de sérieux du
secours à sa place
pris au dépourvu là vous ne savez pas
quoi dire du coup ils en profitent
hop il vous attrape la main il vous
dépose littéralement devant les invités
il s'en va la musique démarre les
invités vous regarde droit dans les yeux
c'est le moment de commencer on ouvre la
bouche et vous ressentez koala
maintenant du stress 1
en tout cas d'ici là ça va vraiment pas
l'air très très agréable il ya de fortes
chances que demain vous disiez mais
j'aurais dû dire ça et c'est normal
parce que le blocage dont nous parlions
précédemment existe encore personne ne
nous a appris à gérer ce blocage et à
dépasser cette peur de parler en public
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas si vous le
saviez mais elle a peur de parler en
public et donc de courir le risque
d'être jugé c'est l'une des peurs et les
plus partagées à travers le monde devant
la pauvreté devant la maladie devant la
mort la peur de parler en public et même
c'est fou non elle est super jeu et même
si on sait d'avancé ce qu'on va dire si
on se place dans le cadre du discours de
mariage et qu'on doit inventer sur le
moment le contenu de la prise de parole
c'est encore bien et c'est là qu'on
parle d'improvisation et dans le cadre
de mon métier d'improvisation théâtrale
c'est la même chose le principe est le
même je monte sur scène je ne sais pas
ce que je vais dire je ne sais pas quel
personnage je vais jouer je ne sais pas
quelle histoire je vais raconter
en fait la seule chose que je sais un
peu comme ce soir c'est que devant moi
et bien un public qui a payé parfois
cher
pour passer une belle soirée bref tous
les soirs ou presque
j'invente de nouveaux discours de
mariage sauf que je suis pas amené
improvisateurs j'ai même pas grandi pour
devenir improvisateurs peut-être
toujours le plus petit asthmatique et
mateu nul en sport zoreil décoller bon
mignon pour certains mais quand même
monstrueux au cours d'autres
si on rajoute à ça que j'ai grandi dans
un environnement qui adorait autoritaire
un peu liberticide j'ai plutôt grandi
dans la soumission et l'impression de ne
pas être intéressant j'avais envie
d'être intéressant mais j'étais persuadé
que rien de ce que je pourrais produire
ne pouvait intéresser qui que ce soit
alors l'idée de me présenter devant des
gens et de partager des choses me
terrifiait comme beaucoup d'êtres
humains j'imagine d'ailleurs alors vous
vous demandez peut-être pourquoi je
continue à faire de l'improvisation
encore et encore et encore et surtout
pourquoi je souris en vous disant eh
bien c'est parce qu'il est une
récompense immédiate à l'improvisation
et cette récompense c'est la créativité
la créativité individuelle la créativité
collective et la créativité immédiate
celle qui jaillit comme par moment comme
par magie un certain moment comme par
exemple des premiers rendez vous
amoureux ou des réunions importantes
donc on a deux dimensions la peur est la
récompense de lutter contre cette peur
qui est la créativité
si on veut espérer pouvoir obtenir un
peu de créativité a besoin
il faut qu'on apprenne à lutter contre
la peur et comme en 8 me contre un
ennemi qu'on connaît bien
il faut qu'on fasse connaissance avec la
peur et donc je prends mes lunettes de
prologue pour vous expliquer comment ça
marche
alors parlons un peu de la peur et plus
précisément de la peur immédiate c'est à
dire la peur qui intervient quand un
danger immédiat survient prenons le cas
suivant imaginez vous vous traversez la
rue et vous
[Applaudissements]
on est d'accord
j'imagine qu'on est tous d'accord
personne ici ne s'est dit oh ça c'est
une kangoo modèle 2009 vitres
électriques
1 je pense que vous avez tous ressenti
la même chose un réflexe est intervenu
très vite et très fort et nous a proposé
trois types de réactions possibles
la première on appelle ça la fuite
active
on court très vite dans l'autre
direction et c'est souvent accompagné
d'un cri très intéressant du typage
deuxième réaction possible la fuite
massive
on ne bouge pas on ne réagit pas dans
l'espoir que si on ne bouge pas la faune
goût ne nous verra pas et enfin
troisième réaction possible
l'attak on contracte tous mes muscles en
prévision du choc et on pense très fort
vient kangoo vient juste à temps
évidemment tout ça c'est une
simplification de la réalité mais elle
permet d'expliquer beaucoup de choses et
j'imagine j'ai l'impression en tout cas
que certains d'entre vous peut-être même
tous vous êtes reconnu dans cette
destruction ce réflexe moi j'aime bien
représentée par un animal particulier
qui est le suricate
mme chirac a donc j'ai pas si vous savez
c'est un petit animal du désert très
très très très très mignons ils se
dressent des cars est un signe de danger
dès qu'un danger intervient il se dresse
puis tous les autres icade du coin
pourquoi parce que la peur immédiate
c'est très très très très très
contagieux mais le jury car tout montre
bien donc le suricate il intervient à
chaque fois qu'il ya une perception de
danger immédiat
et quand il intervient en fait il nous
parle il a un discours il est
excessivement bavard ce suricates si on
reprend l'exemple de du disco du mariage
ou de l'improvisation théâtrale
le suricate que nous dire trois choses
différentes en lien donc avec la fuite
ou la tacc première chose qui peut nous
dire sous pression c'est ne t'ai pas
remarqué hélas le suricate nous dit avec
sa petite voix sympa ne dit rien ne
bouge pas on ne réagit à rien si tu
pouvais avoir aucune idée ce serait
super et en fait les nous censure et la
seule chose qui sort c'est le syndrome
de la page blanche mais de voir des gens
et ça c'est de la fuite
deuxième discours possible de suricates
ok je veux te faire remarquer hockey
soit bon soit vraiment bon soit le
meilleur
hélas le suricate et c'est bas de nous
faire faire 8 choses à la fois il nous
dit essaye d'avoir la meilleure idée
possible juge et évalue toi prépare tout
ce que tu peux contrôler avant même si
cette idole des autres contrôler tout ça
c'est de la tacc envers soi même
évidemment troisième discours possible
de suricates
je veux tu veux te faire remarquer ok tu
veux être bon ok il ya un bon moyen pour
être bon rang l'autre mauvais sur notre
mauvais bompard est meilleure et donc
nos suricates nous dit prend toute la
place décide à la place de l'autre qui
doit faire minimise ce qui va faire
temporise qui va faire contrôler ce qui
va faire l'idée c'est d'attaquer mais
cette fois l'autre celle attaques ni vos
milles alors peut-être que vous n'avez
jamais fait d'improvisation théâtrale
mais pour en avoir parlé avec beaucoup
de personnes de nombreuses fois j'ai le
sentiment que tous nous suricates disent
la même chose
ils essayent de nous rendre mauvais on
nous enfuir ou attaquer et le pire c'est
qu'ils nous disent qu'on a été nuls
quand même alors que c'est ta faute
c'est le fameux à mais j'ai réduit 10 à
dire ça qui continue de nous
culpabiliser longtemps après le moment
d'accord avec ça sympa bon qu'est-ce
qu'on fait que suricates alors a pas
laissé gagner quand même on essaie de
trouver un moyen pour lutter contre lui
merci parce que je vous le rappelle la
récompense immédiate de créativité est
toujours accessible
vous pouvez entraîner votre suricates
différemment vous pouvez dépasser ce
blocage alors comment je vais vous
donner deux outils très simples qui si
vous les utilisez régulièrement
fonctionne très bien ce sont des outils
que les improvisateurs utilise très
régulièrement aussi et ce sont de
formidables moteurs de créativité
premier outil
ça consiste à empêcher entraîner votre
suricates à se dresser en permanence
pour rien à chaque coup de pression pour
ça prenez conscience que le danger
immédiat c'est pas la même chose que le
risque immédiat
le danger d'un côté c'est dangereux et
donc c'est normal que le suricate
interviennent à ce moment là et c'est
même souhaitable parce que là on parle
de survire en revanche de l'autre côté
on a le risque et le risque c'est la
simple possibilité que quelque chose
d'imprévu se produise
c'est tout
notre suricates a rien à faire là et
donc pour vraiment qu'on ne lance robien
le risque c'est la simple possibilité
qui en attribue ce produise plus vous
faites la différence entre le danger et
le risque moins souvent votre sur icade
se dresse et donc plus souvent vous avez
accès à la récompense votre créativité
de naturel qu'avec ça on commence à
s'entraîner tout de suite allez on y va
je m'étais préparé un quizz et donc je
vais vous donner des situations et
j'aimerais que vous me disiez situation
relève plutôt du risque ou plutôt du
danger d'après de moins en moins de
personnes à risques d'henry risque allez
c'est parti
première situation se faire opérer à
coeur ouvert il me dira évidemment
danger on parle de surville deuxième
situation demander à un inconnu dans la
rue de vous prêter son téléphone
portable vous est vachement beau oui
c'est du risque qui peut nous dire oui
peut nous dire non c'est la seule chose
qu'on ne sait pas pas besoin de fuir tu
as besoin d'attaquer n'attaquez pas les
gens dans la rue
troisième situation peut être rater son
bus alors qu'on a rendez vous avec le
petit neveu dans 15 minutes
vous êtes très fort 4ème situation
courir dans les bois la nuit
[Musique]
vous avez raison ça dépend
ça dépend comment vous courrez oui ça
peut dépendre du bois aussi on chipote
dernière situation
le boucher a oublié de vous mettre une
chipolata alors que le barbecue commence
dans 20 minutes
bagnols autrement c'est un piège c'est
très énervant bien sûr il n'y a pas
besoin d'avoir peur tout le temps non
plus calmons nous retenez bien cette
distinction entre le danger immédiat et
le risque immédiat c'est un outil qui
est très très très puissant qui marche
vraiment vraiment très bien je vous
avais promis un deuxième outil je vous
le donne ce deuxième tigre intervient
quand voiture et 4 et quand même dressé
parce que le moment de pression est
arrivé très soudainement ou alors la
pression est vraiment très très forte
lol sur et catella dans ce cas-là
entraîné le à se recoucher comme vous le
savez maintenant en pression ne tuerez
cap nous parle et j'aime souvent à dire
que notre équipe nous harcèlent parce
qu'en plus demandé de ne pas se faire
remarquer vous nous demandez de vraiment
être bon il nous fait ressentir la honte
du moment comment il fait ça nous fait
imaginer toutes les pires conséquences
possibles du ratage qu'il est lui même
en train d'organiser si on prend un
exemple imaginer que je désigne
quelqu'un un public j'ai pas le faire un
job
mais que je désigne quelqu'un dans le
public et que zizou monsieur raconter
une blague maintenant appris ça durait
que quelques secondes mais le suricate
très bien le temps d'être là il aurait
vraiment le temps de susurrer à
l'oreille de sa victime
tout un tas de choses très désagréable
pour qu'il prenne bien conscience de
l'étendue des dégâts
ça peut ressembler non j'ai pas de
blague les gens vont me juger mes amies
elles sauront mon patron va le savoir du
coup j'aurais pas ma promotion
je pourrais pas payer les traites de la
maison ma femme m'a quitté va partir
avec les enfants et le chien aussi sauf
que c'est pas vrai c'est fou c'est le
suricate qui a une imagination
débordante ce qui vous a susurré ce truc
le chien est toujours à la maison il
vous attend avec fierté encore si vous
sentez que votre suricates décident à
votre place de ce que vous devez
imaginer coupé vous de ce monde
imaginaire coupé vous de ce monde qui
est très négatif est très néfaste et
revenez à ce qui se passe maintenant
dans le moment présent et dans le moment
réel le ici et maintenant voici quelques
techniques pour essayer de revenir à ce
moment présent premièrement regarder si
vous avez la chance d'avoir des êtres
humains autour de vous regardez les
autres êtres humains et si possible dans
les yeux ça permet d'ouvrir votre
conscience ça permet de se rendre compte
que d'autres humains à part nous
existent et partagent ce même moment
avec nous c'est une détente quasi-assuré
est quasi immédiate
nous ne sommes pas seuls
deuxième technique pour revenir au
moment présent
respirer ça peut paraître vraiment idiot
mais c'est très important d'apprendre ou
de réapprendre à respirer sous pression
du coup on va le faire maintenant
respirer la respiration c'est une
succession d'inspiration et d'expiration
c'est ce qui permet de faire entrer de
l'air propre et de sortir de l'ère usées
c'est naturel c'est gratuit et c'est
toujours là
du coup c'est un superbe outil pour
revenir dans la présence ancré dans le
moment présent il suffit de temps en
temps de regarder comment on respire
peut-être de visualiser la circulation
d'air et enfin troisième technique sans
doute la plus dure perdre et c'est très
difficile dans les civilisations
actuelle qu'on a maintenant accepté la
possibilité de perdre d'accepter de ne
pas donner 100% du temps le meilleur
possible
et pourtant quand on perd bien quand on
perd avec force quand on perd avec grâce
quand on perd avec un beau sourire et
une belle énergie
tout le monde va mieux d'abord vous
parce que ça y est la pression est
retombée vous venait d'avouer pour les
autres super important aussi parce
qu'ils se rendent compte que ça y est le
danger est passé donc leur propre
suricates se couche le danger immédiat
et très contagieux la détente immédiate
et très contagieux si vous avez
peut-être d'autres techniques qui vous
appartient à vous et qui marche très
bien et dans ce cas là gardé cette
technique chérissent électro tgl elles
sont super si jamais aujourd'hui vous
avez appris des techniques pour vous
débarrasser un petit suricates
j'aimerais pour la dernière fois vous
proposer une visualisation une
expérience et j'aimerais vous rayonnez
je crois que ceux d'hier est emmené mais
je vais dire pourrait emmener au mariage
et donc je vous invite une dernière fois
fermez vos yeux
la musique vient de démarrer tous les
invités vous regarde dans les yeux
prenez conscience qu'il s'agit d'un
risque ici et pas d'un danger il n'y a
aucune kangoo à l'horizon
regardez les invités du mariage regardez
les mariés regardez vous respirez prenez
de l'air souriez mobiliser un peu
d'énergie positive
ouvrez la bouche pour commencer à parler
peut-être avouez que vous n'êtes pas
prêt peut-être que vous pourriez dire je
n'avais pas prévu des plats peut-être
que vous n'aviez pas prévu que je sois
là non plus il fait beau c'est une
superbe journée pour marier mon meilleur
ami me futur meilleur ami se rencontrer
jean-michel saison et c'est resté en
tout cas vous êtes lancé
ouvrez les yeux bravo vous êtes
improvisateurs merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]